what are you doing in your spare time
these days like how do you spend time
it's funny you mentioned it I gamble a
lot I have a lot of fun doing that we go
to Vegas I play Everything poker
Blackjack everything kind of you know I
mean listen I happen to be a degenerate
yeah and it's uh same you say that in a
very like playful way but oh it's not
playful you probably had some terrible
nights where you wanted to [ __ ] it bro
I've been at the casino and I've
genuinely thought about robbing people
yeah that's not not recently yeah not
recently but like that's bad 10 years
ago like 12 years ago when I was doing
radio in Vegas and I'd be at the [ __ ]
Mandalay Bay across the street from the
radio station I'd be down like three
bands which is like my [ __ ]
everything I made for the month
I'll just start I'll be like yo man of
course this [ __ ] high roller room and
try to catch somebody [ __ ] slipping
yeah man that's bad stay away so do you
do you um you play Everything equally
yeah everything kind of equally you know
what I learned uh about gambling is
everything it opened my eyes to like not
even money but everything is relative
you know so when when someone loses a
hundred dollars it's like I've seen rich
people lose you know at a table in in an
hour I've seen them lose 500 000 but
everything is relative so when you see
someone rob someone or kill someone over
you know that hundred dollars you're
like oh it's just a hundred dollars
right it might have been there you know
everything yeah exactly and every it
kind of like put everything into
perspective for me and seeing all these
different walks of life like play with
all this different type of money
and it's opened my eyes you know to like
to how kind of [ __ ] up and twisted
money is oh it's you know and it and it
made me value money a lot less right you
know how because I used to be like yo
this is what money is what we need to
survive but I've just seen so so many
things so many crazy when you gamble
they're it almost like desensitizes you
to the fact you're giving money away it
feels like you're playing a game yeah
because they give you the chips and it's
like oh this is your little chips this
is cute and then you walk away you go
you you go home at the end of the night
and you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] was
real money that's right yeah I uh the
worst is like uh I have a friend who's
made millions of dollars gambling but
I've also seen it like he goes to the
high limit uh slots and he'll deal
he'll do like a thousand two thousand to
[ __ ] spin
and like I've seen him hit for like 900k
yeah like 1.2 million but I also see him
lose I've also seen him been down 300
000 in one day and I'm just like it's a
part of it my God what is your biggest
uh win in gambling and the worst nights
you've ever had in terms of losses I've
had bad knives but like just little
little nights
um my biggest win in gambling was about
quarter million on my birthday and it
was like I was like what the hell like
because I don't really like I believe in
luck but I believe in like
like reality too you know like I don't
think like you go to Vegas and right you
just you're gonna win because it's your
birthday but I won quarter million on my
birthday and I'm just like what what
were you playing [ __ ] black Blackjack
only what yeah quarter million oh my God
that was like a slow come up
no I was like one day no I mean in terms
of like you know some some people will
sit down at a slot machine and hit a
quarter million and [ __ ] like oh yeah
yeah or or they'll play roulette and you
know roulette you could win fast like
black dress it's not slow when you're
betting five thousand ten thousand it's
pretty fast you'd be there for three
four hours you either lose everything or
you win we have 250. 250 and I'm like
that must have been the best birthday of
your life I was like this is so crazy I
was telling my girl I was like this is
like is this birthday look like what's
going on oh my goodness it was so cool I
can't imagine a better birthday yeah
ever yeah but then it also made me
realize like you know all this money
like uh it's it's
don't let me be up 250 on my birthday in
Vegas I'm gonna be at the [ __ ] I don't
know if you know who he is you you know
Mickey Mickey dude he'll be rolling
around Vegas craziest that's mommy he's
he's like I learned from him the real
degenerate life like he's he's he's won
millions millions and a weekend stretch
there is like real like strategy if you
really gamble the right way that all of
it's luck based but there is certain
things like roulette there's certain
ways you could play exactly where you
have like an advantage on the house if
you got a big enough bankroll uh that's
the the only the only Advantage you have
really in gambling you just have to have
the bankroll you know don't try to be
able to back your losses yeah exactly so
if you played you play Relax yeah yeah
so I've ever done the strategy where you
bet two-thirds at once so yeah the
second thirds third third first second
yeah
and then if you lose you triple each
time and
when I was living in Vegas yeah that's
what I would do I'd go to like Fremont
Street where it was like did it work out
for you mostly or didn't yeah but I'd be
there for like five or six hours and be
up like 400 bucks but for me at the time
I was missing that's 32 Grand a year
yeah it's it's all relative but
roulette's fun I like to bet on the
numbers because when that [ __ ] hits you
just get high you're like no that's the
dopamine hit of winning and gambling is
like nothing else yeah and that's why
it's a problem oh like when I watch
sports and I have a bunch of money going
on a [ __ ] game and it's close and I
win bro it's like I [ __ ] have 30
orgasms yeah no for real that's what but
that's why when I lose problems that's
why it's addicting I'm [ __ ] sick
oh I've been there I've been there yeah
so my worst gambling stretches always
had to do with sports and it was always
sports betting from my house yeah
yeah because I've had some rough run
when I gamble man I really like to just
have fun right if I'm if I'm there
stressing or anything like that it
usually never works out for me right and
it's kind of a waste when you lose
because it's like damn you didn't use so
if you were up 250 in the night biggest
worst night that you've walked away um
nothing nothing bad because I don't I'm
not like doing anything crazy maybe you
know 10 20 30. I mean it's really like
that [ __ ] but you know everything it
kind of all even I lost fortunes
okay
I'd probably be divorced
yeah
I'd be like sorry shit's uh you know uh
I don't know what happened I thought I
was I
James Harden he [ __ ] up just blaming
all the players yeah it's literally all
I could do right because I lost like 15
Christmas week ones oh no not Chris
Christmas week that's what I just blamed
it on James Harden because it was his
[ __ ] fault
that's the worst Christmas week [ __ ]
James Harden yeah I love Vegas man
there's a guy named Mike White from the
Jets who [ __ ] started a game last
year against the Bengals cost me 10
bands [ __ ] Mike White too
yeah you got a sports gambling's fun
though yeah I'm just not too not too
into sports I feel like you have no
control and the other thing too is like
you could also bet on like these like
really zany weird like celebrity boxing
matches yeah which I haven't done yet
I've seen yeah I have not done that but
there's like online Sports books that
will like take your like blue face fight
money or whatever whoever's fighting
like yeah and it's like those I feel
like you could kind of figure out